women who hate their husbands are the
ones
that are submissive as well
pretending to be maybe
not even what do you mean submissive to
their husbands
so the husband's like
the lead the leader of the relationship
and they hate them
because they say then it's the wrong
kind of leadership yeah that's yeah
that's true it depends
it's the wrong kind of leadership
it might not really be leadership it
could just be bullying or overpowering
them in a situation and then that's
wrong
a real real submission that we're
talking about is a more kind of
do you guys think it's um
okay do you think it's fair for women to
want traditional men that pay and take
care of them and take us on dates all
that stuff well we're not traditional
women so like we're not virgins anymore
we're not like we don't offer the
traditional if you can't because you
can't clean your traditional women
yes yes no i'm just saying no no i
didn't hear you go ahead if you want a
traditional man you have to be a
traditional woman like don't get mad
when he expects you to stay at bst at
her mom quick and clean and stuff like
that
because that's how it works
but yeah you put it that's why i don't
want a traditional man because i know it
comes with that price
at the price of
really i would if i could stay home i'd
be chilling
at home all day oh yeah i mean look
after the kids cook clean when he comes
home and wash his yeah watch his
underwear like that's just again i'm
gonna ask did your mom do that stuff
yes
yes
i don't like that but just saying you're
fighting against you're fighting against
it but it's there for you to see and
it's been successful your parents are
still together because they're
successful just because they're together
doesn't mean it's successful that's true
that's not something i aspire you know
so i'm asking though your parents have
so you're saying they're not they can be
happy but i wasn't the happiness the
success i mean like for you for them not
for you for them yeah but for me
that's not what i
personally i understand i'm just i'm
just saying for them they've achieved
happiness for them yeah
you don't think that's an indicator of
success
that's the point i'm trying to make yeah
but it's like 50 of marriages end in
divorce so the fact that your parents
are still together and don't hate each
other is a w
huge that's that's huge after how long
have they been together it's
over
over five years
and you don't think there's anything you
could learn from that relationship i
mean i can pick up a couple of things
right it's like don't get tricked don't
get tricked out of position where these
the
the new the feminism lies to women they
it lies no radical feminism does
i think all feminism i don't think we
need feminism in 2022. i think it's
outdated and there's nothing that i
can't do today that a man can do there's
no nothing legally in my way
like there's no law we're fighting for i
i don't see the name right that's
different for every woman so like say
for example me and you uh-huh you can
walk into an office and demand a job
they'll give it to you if i ask for it
they'll be like what is this black
monkey doing here like get out
and then say for example you and a man
if you both walked in okay say for
example you and a white man okay
okay he's more like oh sorry he's more
likely to get the job than you
there's still that type of
thing
that's not true that's not true the wage
gap doesn't exist
it doesn't when you take into account
the diff no it doesn't like any any
psychologist that's worth assault will
tell you that it does not exist the
people that the people that the people
that
are that that talk about that are
reiterating it for their political gain
they're saying that to confuse you and
to control you i mean i've seen it no no
no no so so the reason when you take
into account
personality differences
and and roles that women pick so women
tend to pick jobs that are with people
men tend to pick jobs with things so
therefore men make more money because
those jobs pay more for example men pick
engineering more than women that's a
very high paying career
men pick plumbing
bricklaying
garbage garbage collection that stuff is
that pays more than being like a
psychologist
[Laughter]
um
studies that i've seen so i did a study
on like
basketball okay it's quite evident the
men get paid a lot more than me because
they bring in because because they bring
in more money i know they're bringing
more money but so so why would you pay
someone if they're not making money like
that's like me that's like if you have
more money they could probably perform
to the level where they'd get the same
amount of money
no no they don't the wnba is at a 10
million loss every year they lose money
they don't make money
so so that's like me having 10 salesmen
and the men
bring me in let's say 50k each a year
then women lose me 20k but are they
given the same facilities because you
could be giving these men fancy offices
and then the women's workforce
do you think that lebron james dunking
is more entertaining
as equally as entertaining as like the
one or two women that conduct
a woman duncan is quite impressive yeah
it's because men don't all the time so
it's just like it's impressive it's
impressive but is it as entertaining
do you i think so well that's me either
someone else the exception or the rule
do more people want to watch the nba or
the wnba it depends on which one's
publicized more which is the mba but
it's not as publicized
no it's because men are men are better
at basketball well i didn't want to say
that's the bottom line i play i play
basketball
and even even at let's take uel
i'm sorry i'd rather watch the men's
over us true
that way though
in what we in the sense that
as you mentioned before in terms of the
pay gap or the one doesn't exist
obviously men will take more laborious
jobs right so the more the engineering
things actually takes on the physicality
of a man yeah
hence why us women get paid less we do
the admin jobs the personal jobs yeah
when you're comparing it versus football
to football for example my cousin she's
a female she plays football
she actually posts something yesterday
the pay gap in football is mad
and i was and i see what you're saying
about what would you rather watch but
why is it why do you want to watch men
play football versus women's yeah
far better yeah
they have better facilities no they're
better because of the physicalities and
the genetics the biology
cardio kicking a ball cardless it's not
just about it
it's
who would win in an arm wrestling match
oh absolutely exactly that's different
the boris things but yeah you know in
the sense of an exactly it's the same
game basketball football it's the same
game no but these things do come into
play strength yeah yeah yeah
that comes into it does come into play
we're just better at it the closest i've
seen to the gap being pushed to a degree
is tennis with the williams sisters but
they're still yeah
where they play to such a level but
yeah the 200th
ranked man beat serena williams thank
you i was about to say that
yeah like men are just better at sports
they're bigger they're stronger they're
faster so you deserve to get paid more
yeah they yeah because if you're better
at a job you get paid more absolutely so
why don't they'll ever have a chance to
bring the gap nice how so you're
battling against dna and genetics like
just the same way i think there's like
men will never bridge the gap in
modeling but you don't hear anything
about that
you don't hear men complaining oh we
don't make as much on only fans like
we don't even though even though it's
the same even though nobody like that
industry was built by men anyway so most
that's the men's fault anyway
what so only friends like porn industry
that's basically built by men so it's
the men's fault that they don't get
enough views
i know so what's the difference
men watch sports
yeah yeah so i'm saying like like at the
end of the day you get paid for eyeballs
in both professions you get paid for who
watches more yeah and so one it's women
taking off their clothes and men taking
off clothes and in the other it's
playing a sport
yes so but i'm saying like why don't
nobody
rallies marches the streets
for i agree with you
for the men not getting paid enough to
model yes i think i mean they're not
really triggered by it
no because men don't complain women do
women women women will complain about
everything i'm complaining if i wasn't
earning enough money
that the money you'd complain if you
don't earn the money if you're earning
the money you deserve to earn
basically i feel like they deserve it i
think they deserve less actually if
you're operating at a loss i think they
probably don't like if we're going to go
off with deserve like if if i had a
sales person and they were losing me
money like
ish right there he has a job because i
make more money on the streams than he
like than he costs
right
but if we if these streams were really
bad and every time i lost viewers every
time he came on like
he wouldn't be here and it's the same
thing with like the wnb and the nba
they have they have people yes if it was
performance related play related pay a
lot of these women wouldn't there might
be no basketball league for women
[Music]
but i think it's probably because it's
more recent thing
what's that you think as time goes by
women will get better
no because i feel like the men have had
a head start if that makes sense so
basketball
i didn't want to start patching it up
but in biology
a head start
no but in terms of like leagues these
are still new leagues uh-huh so
that's on tennessee because the demand
for the men's league was there like i'm
telling you people want to make money
people like
people will put anything on a screen to
make money if women's sports made money
it would be pushed
they just did the boxing the other day
in new york they did um
the big all-women's fight first time
every madison square garden
um katy taylor versus amanda serrano
that got a big push
that was a landmark moment
but again how much of that was partly
like
the novelty of it at the same time
because
you know men do that every week
i do i do you think women should box do
you like women boxing
if they like it then they like it i
personally don't like boxing as a whole
but they're saying if i don't mind they
might as well both box if two women were
boxing
and one and one of them battered bruce
getting enough would you do you think
you'd be more inclined to say stop the
fight than you would if it was two men
you're not in yeah i want to see women
fighting wood
you've gone into fight and now you want
to stop the fight just continue
if she dies she does
nice i'm saying instinctively you you
might want to like that emily said she
would be more inclined to say i would i
would yes and i would as well so i'm
saying it that's just me that i'm like
she's like
she's like a lot of guys
why are you crying like hers making out
alive